now to that special report and
president-elect joe biden speaking about
the economy let's go ahead and listen
to do when they hear what we have in
mind
i'm very pleased that it all came
together around the same
table to advance areas of common ground
and we agreed we're going to continue
these conversations
they represent very different
perspectives but i'm convinced that we
can all come together around the same
table
to advance areas of common ground which
are
really i wish you could have all heard
the conversation
it was really encouraging and that's
what we were ready to discuss today
we all agreed that we want to get the
economy back on track we need our
workers to be back on the job
by getting the virus under control we're
going in a very dark winter
things are going to get much tougher
before they get easier and that requires
sparing no effort to fight coven
so that we can open our businesses
safely resume our lives and put this
pandemic behind us
it's going to be difficult but it can be
done and they all agreed
that means rallying the country behind a
national strategy with robust public
health measures
like mandatory masking widely available
testing with rapid results
scaled up production of life-saving
treatments and therapeutics
and safe equitable and free distribution
of the vaccine
it's great news that modern and pfizer
have each come up
with vaccines that are in excess of 90
effectiveness
and getting the vaccine and a
vaccination
though are two different things everyone
on our call today in our zoom today
agreed that the sooner we have access to
the administration's distribution plan
the sooner this transition would be
smoothly
move forward and you know as we battle
covert
we also make sure the business and
workers have the tools the resources
the national guidance and health and
safety standards to operate safely
and we can do that we can bring
democrats and republicans together
work with business and labor to deliver
those necessary resources
and for millions of americans who've
lost hours and wages
or have lost their jobs we all agree on
our call
that we can deliver immediate relief and
in need be done
quickly affordable health care for
millions of people who have lost it
or in danger of losing it child care
sick leave
family need so workers don't have to
choose between work and family
corporate america agreed on this today
the
provokes on the call we need support of
small to support small businesses and
entrepreneurs
that are the backbone of our communities
but are teetering on the edge
and we all agreed on the urgent need for
funding for states and localities
to keep frontline workers and essential
workers on the job
vital public services running law
enforcement
offices education listening livestream
president-elect joe biden
discussing the economy also the news
from both pfizer and moderna that they
have a vaccine
that is at least 90 percent effective
also speaking
about safety efforts keeping the country
safe also keeping businesses safe and
afloat
as we continue to battle the chronovirus
pandemic you can continue to watch that
it is streaming live on eightnewsnow.com